[Música]
en primera plana
braulio moro
[Música]
bienvenidos a en primera plana una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 en español
dedicada al análisis de la actualidad de
la semana joe biden es ya el 46
presidente de los eeuu asume esa
presidencia con un país profundamente
dividido con una crisis sanitaria como
nunca antes y con una muy pesada
herencia la del ex presidente donald
trump para hablar de ello saludamos ya
aquí en nuestros estudios al mar bassets
ex corresponsal del país y en washington
autor del otoño americano bienvenido
marca muchas gracias
asimismo a la larga inning ex
corresponsal del new york times' es
experto en relaciones méxico-estados
unidos autor de un libro de referencia
vecinos distantes bienvenido a la cndh
gracias y también contaremos con el
análisis de isabela alanís profesora y
subjefe del departamento de gobierno y
política de la universidad de marineland
presidencia by de cómo salir de la
crisis estamos en primera plana
[Música]
joe biden ha asumido su cargo en
condiciones excepcionales en un país que
vive una situación excepcional una
capital rodeada por más de 25 mil
soldados de la guardia nacional con
fuertes divisiones con un país donde
están por producirse casi 500.000
muertos a causa del rotavirus y una
sociedad dividida como nunca antes
cuáles son esos desafíos que enfrentará
vamos a ver lo que dicen al respecto
algunas portadas de la prensa
internacional
comenzamos con el boston globe que
titula tiempo para el cambio en eeuu
en la vecina chicago el 'chicago
tribune' escribe inauguración imponentes
desafíos esperan a los nuevos líderes
aquí en francia el conservador le figaro
escribió en portada yo he vaivén un
mandato para reconciliar a eeuu y
finalmente del otro lado del atlántico
en américa del sur el clarín de buenos
aires titula apenas asumió vaivén frenó
la construcción del muro con méxico
vamos a comenzar con una pregunta a
nuestros invitados de una manera y de
una respuesta muy breve como resumen los
cuatro años de la presidencia
donald trump marc lo resumiría con tres
frases el mayor reality show de la
historia o el mayor circo de la historia
una pesadilla americana y un cambio de
época a escala global y en particular en
las democracias occidentales pesadilla
show alan como resumen muy brevemente la
presidencia de donde el tonto sin hacer
una lista de todas las locuras que
cometió
que un ejemplo de la explotación del
sentido de resentimiento es un hombre de
resentido el supo sentir y explotar el
resentimiento de mucha gente y eso
explica por qué todavía en esta última
elección él tuvo más de 70 millones de
votos muy bien pues aquí tiene ya una
manera muy concreta lo que es el resumen
lo que piensan muchos analistas este
respecto vamos a ver también lo que
piensan los seguidores de los seguidores
de donald trump
recordemos simplemente que joe biden ha
iniciado su mandato con una serie de
decretos ha firmado 17 decretos en los
que se puede destacar notablemente por
ejemplo lo que tiene que ver con la
política migratoria reintegrará a su
país a la organización mundial de la
salud asimismo ha firmado la integran
corporación de eeuu al acuerdo de país
sobre el cambio climático pero y sobre
todo sobre todo ha lanzado una campaña
nacional para iniciar un programa de
vacuna contra el coronavirus recuerdo
que hay más de 24 millones de
estadounidenses que han sido víctimas
contagiados por esta pandemia y ha
prometido que su mandato
dedicado precisamente a reunificar ese
país
marc lo más sencillo es firmar decretos
es una tradición en eeuu llega un
mandatario inmediatamente puede firmar
los decretos paraná lugar anular algunas
de las decisiones que juzgan no
pertinentes del mandato anterior eso es
muy sencillo el problema es que va a ser
el para proponer para hacer avanzar su
programa hay cuando tiene que negociar
con el congreso si el de los de los
decretos que ha firmado yo byd en los
primeros días esto es como dices es una
tradición y marca la ruptura y marca el
cambio de gobierno el cambio de tono el
cambio de políticas incluso el cambio
ideológico pero eeuu es un país de
contrapoderes y el presidente no
gobierna solo y necesita el congreso
ambas cámaras la cámara de
representantes y el senado
yo vaivén tiene la suerte si se puede
decir que las elecciones recientes
el partido demócrata su partido
consiguió una muy pequeña mayoría pero
pequeña mayoría que facilitará la tarea
de poner en marcha sus políticas y que
conseguir apoyos pero esto no significa
que vaya a ser muy fácil
barack obama tuvo durante los dos
primeros años de su primer mandato
mayoría en el senado y o bien muchas de
sus iniciativas no prosperaron o
quedaron de totalmente descafeinada en
el proceso legislativo ya hay el punto
de la adicional
efectivamente el decreto permiten no
pasar por el congreso esto es lo más
sencillo pero además como convencer a
esos millones de electores esos más de
70 millones a los que hacía referencia a
la que siguen confiando en que donald
trump ganó si esto esto es esto el gran
problema de eeuu y yo diría de muchas
democracias de este mundo pero el estado
unidos en particular
es un país muy dividido siempre lo ha
sido hay que decir pero ahora es verdad
que hay millones de decenas de millones
de estadounidenses no creen ni reconocen
a este presidente y seguramente esta
será la primera tarea que no no me
parece fácil creo que la batalla
ideológica y la batalla yo bailé en el
sur inaugural habló de la necesidad de
reconocer la verdad distinguir la verdad
y la mentira es que es casi es casi una
un concepto filosófico pero hemos
llegado a tal punto después de la
presidencia de trump que aquí se discute
si existe la verdad y si la verdad puede
diferenciarse de la mentira ya no es
cuestión de políticas públicas de
presupuestos de políticas migratorias de
políticas medioambientales no es verdad
o mentira y hace y conseguir que haya un
mínimo consenso sobre los hechos este es
el gran reto y gran desafío de abordar
vamos a volver precisamente a la ayer el
presidente ha dado su primera
conferencia de prensa y la ha dedicado a
lo que anunció durante la toma de
posición precisamente el programa
nacional de vacunas
decíamos son más de 25 millones
de estadounidenses que han sido
contaminados por el coronavirus baile
prevee que habrá medio millón de muertos
el mes entrante y al mismo tiempo
100.000 de los que ya ayer exacta de las
2.100 bng y además plantea ni más ni
menos que va a poner 100 millones de
personas en los primeros 100 días de su
mandato es posible esta tarea
pero los eeuu tienen una enorme fuerza
mucho dinero mucha organización si el
hecho es que con trump no se ha hecho ni
mucho esfuerzo el paso del producto en
los estados los estados estaban bien
dividido entre estados gobernados por
gobernadores republicanos que querían
quedar bien con trump y no había una
estrategia nacional ahora se supone que
la estrategia nacional y para bailan es
esencial porque todo su gobierno de los
cuatro años depende del éxito de eso
porque es sin que avance sola sobre las
vacunas y la pandemia no puede hacer
nada y no olvidemos que en 22 meses a
elección entonces tiene 22 meses para
resolver problemas de anemia y empezar a
resolver los problemas y completar las
cumplir las promesas que hizo para el
bien del pueblo en general sea de la
inmigración sea de la pobreza hacer mil
problemas la lista enorme pero a veces
perdón pero hay una parte que simbólica
relativamente que es la firma de los
decretos aquí es un programa concreto
y yo voy a vacunar cien millones pero en
este caso cómo va a ser el por ejemplo
ha decidido que a nivel federal la gente
tendrá que utilizar mascarilla que entre
otras cosas en estados donde hasta ahora
no sólo hay gente seguidores de tron que
dicen esto no sirve para nada claro no
creemos en la pandemia cómo va a imponer
eso hace la pregunta es capaz de imponer
esa situación bueno lo va a hacer un
poco por ejemplo por presión vamos a ver
no porque hay es esta resistencia que
vivimos tan dramáticamente hace dos
semanas en washington el ataque sobre el
congreso de este tipo de resistencia
bueno vamos a ver hasta qué punto se
traduce
supongamos que una buena parte de los
americanos de los eeuu entiende que es
una situación muy crítica entonces
materia de concesiones no se debe
imponer y la gente hay una gente que hay
parte los a dos minutos de los
americanos que tiene por casi por
instinto de resistir a cualquier
intervención del estado de todas de
washington en especie de enemigo
fantasma que inventaron todos los
políticos gastan tránsito los otros
entonces no no tengo una respuesta a eso
es como decir veamos aquí en europa
todas las promesas de se ha hecho de lo
que se iba a hacer con con las con las
vacunas o aun aún antes entonces no sé
vamos a ver si puede pero lo que digo es
que todos todo lo que vamos a hablar hoy
depende de lo que pasa en la pandemia
muy bien marc durante su discurso baile
justamente reconoció que el extremismo
avanzó durante la administración de
donald trump ya no también el terrorismo
una expresión fue la toma del capitolio
justamente el pasado 6 de enero si es el
terrorismo interior que hemos pasado en
nuestras sociedades desde el 11 de
septiembre de 2001 con la preocupación
la alarma y la amenaza del terrorismo
islamista terrorismo
y la presidencia de trampa ha supuesto
un cambio una inflexión también en este
en este sentido y en la última fase y
hace dos semanas en el asalto al
capitolio ha emergido y se ha visto a la
luz del día que existe bueno un
terrorismo una violencia no sabemos la
puede llamar yo bailé llamado terrorismo
así con es con estas palabras a interno
a que amenaza a eeuu y que es una teoría
como se vio en el día jornada inaugural
la protección de la guardia nacional la
prueba de la militarización de la
capital de eeuu no era por al qaeda ni
por el estado islámico era por
estadounidenses que amenazaban a su
propio gobierno y en su propia
democracia cómo va a poder hacer para
reducir precisamente ese riesgo sabiendo
que de los 75 millones de
estadounidenses que votaron por donald
trump sólo un 19% de si estamos hablando
de 15 millones dicen ok vaivén cando
pero tiene 60 que siguen reivindicando
que donde el trompo cayó bueno
intentemos ser un poco de optimistas
cabe esperar que habrá un que puede
haber un momento de apaciguamiento y de
calma eeuu ha habido en la tensión
en los últimos cuatro años con esta
polarización y la tensión atizada y
azuzada por el propio presidente de eeuu
ahora finalmente la la democracia
estadounidense ha demostrado que
pese a todo funciona ha habido una
transición de poder hay un nuevo
presidente que ha llegado con un mensaje
de calma y de unidad es posible yo creo
que es posible contemplar que por lo
menos durante un tiempo habrá sino
aquellos cien días de gracia que antes
se decía que tenían los presidentes y
que obviamente esto desde hace tiempo ya
no ocurre si un poco de benevolencia
hacia hacia este nuevo presidente y la
salida de yo creo que la salida de
donald trump
favorece esto propicia esto tram no ha
salido bien
el asalto al capitolio dio una imagen de
eeuu y una imagen de la presidenta eeuu
que incluso muchos tram pistas o muchos
republicanos les hizo sentirse incómodos
les cuesta distanciarse pero no se
sintieron bien se vieron en un espejo
que no les gustó nada yo creo que esto
puede ayudarle la retirada de trump
puede ayudar a calmar los ánimos vamos a
hacer una pausa en unos minutos más
volveremos aquí en primera plana
ah
[Música]
en turquía aunque sea criticar levemente
al presente turco recep tayip erdogán
acarrea consecuencias judiciales para
varios miles de personas cada año antes
de que erdogán fuese investido como
presidente turco en 2015 años antes
había sido ya primer ministro el número
total de personas condenadas por
insultos al presidente un crimen muy
antiguo que data de 1923 fue de 44
personas en toda la historia de la
república de turquía desde 2015 hasta
2019 en el último año del que se tienen
datos han sido seis mil personas las
condenadas por este crimen insultos al
jefe de estado turco las redes sociales
han vuelto ahora mismo un sitio donde la
policía controla al dedillo cualquier
palabra o crítica que pueda recibir el
presente turco y según muchos abogados
de defensa y de derechos humanos turcos
las denuncias de los fiscales turcos
contra gente que insulta al presidente
son diarias y casi por defecto
[Música]
en españa las injurias a la corona son
un delito que puede ser castigado con
hasta dos años de cárcel y son muchos
los casos de cantantes de políticos
activistas e incluso de periodistas de
revistas satíricas que fueron condenados
por este delito en la mayoría a multas
importantes pero está también el caso
del político arnaldo otegi condenado a
un año de cárcel por decir que el rey de
españa era el jefe de los torturadores
para este caso como para otros el
tribunal europeo de derechos humanos
condenó a españa por vulnerar la
libertad de expresión y hay tanta
polémica aquí que incluso a finales del
año pasado se presentó una proposición
de ley para despenalizar este delito
pero fue rechazada por parte del
gobierno por el partido socialista entre
otros porque según ellos este delito
protege el honor y la reputación del
estado
[Música]
uncharted recibió la sentencia más dura
en la historia de tailandia bajo la ley
de lesa majestad esta ex funcionaria fue
condenada a 43 años y seis meses de
prisión por compartir audios en facebook
y youtube en los que se criticaba a la
monarquía el caso ha sido el símbolo del
endurecimiento de la ley aunque la norma
existe desde principios del siglo 20
tailandia lo había dejado de usar pero
esto cambió el año pasado cuando las
protestas sociales se recrudecieron por
primera vez los tailandeses comenzaron a
criticar abiertamente a la familia real
una de las más ricas del mundo y en
noviembre del 2020 diego la reactivación
de la ley de lesa majestad que dejara
aprilia en la cárcel por el resto de su
vida
[Música]
estamos de vuelta aquí en primera plana
en compañía de nuestros invitados
marc bassets ex corresponsal del país en
españa y de alan riding que fuera
corresponsal de the new york times vamos
a escuchar a propósito de lo que son uno
de los grandes desafíos de joe biden es
decir cómo conciliar no solo a la
sociedad sino al interior mismo del
partido demócrata
vamos a escuchar lo que nos dice a este
respecto la analista
isabel a alcañiz buenos días
pay del anuncio en su discurso de
inauguración qué
él quiere hacer un gobierno de unidad y
creo que una forma concreta de acercarse
a todos los americanos es resolviendo
uno de los problemas más urgentes más
trágicos que asola el país que es el de
la pandemia y evidentemente la
administración baiden está pensando que
esta es una de sus prioridades más
importantes pero hay un sector del
electorado del partido republicano lo
que sería el movimiento de los
seguidores de trump y otros que han
demostrado actitudes sediciosas y
violentas que no pueden ser
reconciliadas y deben ser reconciliadas
un sector del partido republicano que se
ha ido polarizando cada vez más
-sector que hace dos semanas atrás
mostró cuán peligroso puede ser para la
democracia de este país en parte es un
problema generado o por lo menos
tolerado por la cúpula del partido
republicano entonces ahí también hay
responsabilidad han hecho una alianza y
a veces cuando se hace alianza con
sectores extremistas tal vez no a veces
tal vez siempre hay unos riesgos muy
altos y entonces creo que eso es lo que
se vio en forma clara el 6 de enero pero
en realidad ha habido voces de alerta ya
hace muchos años incluso antes de
transporte antes de trump fue el
movimiento del partido del té
que también era un movimiento cada vez
más marginal a la política partidaria
centrista de eeuu si bien es isabel
calles profesoras y subjefe del
departamento de gobierno y política de
la universidad de mar isla o alan que
piensas a este propósito
mire ahí ella tiene toda la razón que
siempre ha existido una extrema derecha
en los eeuu y ha sido dramática
dramáticamente ha sido aumentado por
trump es decir él dio oxígeno todos los
días todos todas las semanas y eso es lo
que lo infló puede la democracia digamos
normal sensata en los estados puede
existir
con una extrema derecha normal ni
pequeña pero se desbordó ahora la
cuestión es si el nivel político del
partido republicano senado y cámara
ellos
y me den porque ellos también son
políticos y buscan su interés entonces
van a ser los senadores por ejemplo con
la cuestión del impeachment es que
algunos suficientes por lo menos diez
para añadir a los cincuenta de los
demócratas para para condenar lo serán
decir mira el tiempo de trampa a cabo a
mí me conviene pensar en el futuro yo
voy a votar vamos a eliminar trump y
vamos a reconstruir un partido
republicano que tiene más más normalidad
otros del puede decir no todavía
yo tengo una elección en 22 meses
todavía este este este pueblo
republicano tram pista me va a castigar
si toma una posición entonces en este
momento aunque estamos viendo al país
entero lo que pasa y todo un campo a la
expectativa mucho depende de las
posiciones que toman los altos niveles
políticos del partido republicano muy
bien esta es una parte que tiene que ver
con la situación al respecto al partido
republicano
vamos a escuchar ahora también lo que
nos dice isabel alaníz a propósito de lo
que es la situación al interior del
partido demócrata porque claro también
también hay el ala izquierda del partido
demócrata que no está muy contenta con
la situación actual que escuchemos la me
parece una apuesta al futuro porque los
demócratas a diferencia del sector más
duro republicanos entienden que el
cambio demográfico es implacable y que
hay que apostar
todos estos grupos por ahora
minoritarios porque van a ser el futuro
mayoritario del electorado de eeuu pero
además el gabinete que es cierto es
histórico por lo diverso por esta
representatividad de sectores que han
estado marginales son marginalizados de
la política también hay que decir que es
un gabinete en contraste con el gobierno
inmediatamente anterior de una profunda
idoneidad y capacidad técnica que no
quiere decir que haya acuerdo en la
política pública que cada jefa jefe de
cartera de las secretarías van a
defender no hay diversidad así también
la jce hay algunos secretarios que
serían como los ministros que son de
representan más la política del ala
progresista del partido demócrata y hay
otros que representan
centrista o incluso más conservadora
entonces ahí sigue habiendo diferencias
ideológicas de políticas de posturas de
puertas para adentro en el partido una
situación de equilibrio muy complicada
marc vaivén ha hecho muchas promesas al
final de cuentas no existe el riesgo de
que muchas de esas promesas acaben
estrellándose en el muro de los
compromisos políticos
el riesgo existe siempre pero yo creo
que al contrario de lo que ocurrió con
obama que llegó como un casi como un
salvador como un santo que iba a curar
las heridas de eeuu y del mundo
hayden es un hombre mayor bastante mayor
a 78 años no tiene excesivo carisma
lleva en política 50 años
a nadie espera de una revolución una
transformación yo creo que lo que se
espera de él es que calme
al país y en parte al mundo no después
de los cuatro años de trámites verdad y
muchas promesas pero creo que las
expectativas tampoco en ese sentido son
son tan elevadas como las que pudo haber
con barack obama cuando cuando llegó al
poder una de esas promesas convertidas
ya por lo menos un inmediato en realidad
a la ha sido entre los decretos que
firmó están la suspensión de la
construcción del muro en la frontera sur
con méxico en este sentido hay que
recordar que donald kohn había hecho de
esa de la construcción de ese muro uno
de los pilares de sus campañas de su
presidencia
concretamente logró construir a avanzar
380 kilómetros sobre más de 2.200
kilómetros de frontera es un mensaje muy
fuerte hacia méxico y hacia los países
de centroamérica pero independientemente
de eso cuáles son los puntos donde
podría chocar la administración vaivén
con mexico y cuáles son los puntos donde
podrá caminar conjuntamente bueno
concretamente sobre el cuestión de la
inmigración es no tanto la inmigración
de mexicanos pero el problema de américa
central sobre todo de honduras el
salvador y guatemala entonces méxico
a lópez obrador es un compromiso con
trump esencialmente para controlar la
entrada sea a la frontera de guatemala y
méxico o la frontera lusa drews
controlar este este movimiento y que va
a volver el programa ya sabemos esto es
un creado únicamente de honduras una
marcha si se ha contenido
confrontaciones en guatemala es decir
este problema va a volver a ser un
problema porque antes es muy fácil decir
que camps es un hombre que no tiene
ningún sentido humano para estos pobres
gentes madres niños separados todo tipo
de cosas pero este programa 'volver lo
que hizo
byd en esencialmente fue un acto
simbólico porque como el muro era un
símbolo de la campaña de trump que
obviamente fracasó porque méxico no pagó
y tampoco avanzó 400 kilómetros más o
menos pero no mucho más entonces es
decir pero era una especie de símbolo de
ese entonces
eliminamos este símbolo pero no ha
eliminado el problema hay miles y miles
de centroamericanos y otros en la
frontera de méxico con estados esperando
teóricamente poder ser entrevistados
para ver si tienen derecho de asilo y
hay después millones de centroamericanos
pero millones que con la oportunidad y
dos niños entonces cómo va a ser eso y
sabiendo que la reacción en el media
médica en el medio la parte en donde
central en los estados a nivel de vigo
central en el sentido físico y yo creo
que la que hoy también el central para
el partido republicano donde hay ahí
una resistencia inmigración fue todavía
hoy simplemente recordar que además el
presidente joe biden se ha comprometido
ha lanzado una propuesta de regularizar
a aproximadamente 11 millones de
inmigrantes que viven todavía hoy de
manera ilegal en eeuu en los próximos 10
años hay muchos temas que hablar de la
materia internacional de manera breve en
marc uno de los grandes temas él ha
dicho hay que reconstruir alianzas
estamos pensando en europa cuál podría
ser el principal punto para volver a
construir un puente de alianza entre los
eeuu y la unión europea que no pase por
lo tanto evidentemente pero que ofrezca
una nueva alternativa de esa potencia
que es los eeuu finalmente bueno aquí
también ha habido decisiones simbólicas
en los primeros días como es el regreso
al acuerdo de parís el regreso a la
organización mundial de la salud que han
enviado el mensaje en efecto a europa ya
los aliados históricos de eeuu de que
para estado unidos vuelve al
multilateralismo vuelve las
organizaciones internacionales
y vuelve a las alianzas la sensación en
europa me parece en las capitales
europeas es que nada volverá a ser igual
que trampa no fue un paréntesis que eeuu
y el mundo están cambiados y que están
acá han cambiado en estos años y que los
intereses no siempre serán convergentes
no es un aliado más fiable como antes es
eso no es un aliado fiable como como
antes porque puede pasar que gane otro
trump sin extra otro presidente que
decida pues como trampa amenaza con
marcharse del lado de la otan trampa
puesto sobre la mesa y quizá es una
virtud que se le puede reconocer a trump
por unos problemas que existían ahí que
llevaban tiempo discutiendo sé pero que
nunca se habían expuesto de manera tan
brutal como este presidente en por
ejemplo con la otan hasta que fue una
organización creada para la guerra fría
y que desde entonces busca busca su
sentido trampa decía que la otra le
importaba muy poco pero también el
presidente francés emmanuel macro me
dijo que la otan se encuentraban en
situación de muerte cerebral es decir
hay unos la alianza transatlántica entre
europa y eeuu
a reformularse aunque sea con la
administración vaivén que es un
administración europeísta con discreta
área de estado que ha vivido en parís
que conoce francia etcétera etcétera
aún así el mundo ha cambiado y la
relación men cambiará también 30
segundos 30 segundos para cada uno la
herencia de tron va a ser difícil de
borrar 30 segundos por favor a la base
sobre todo domésticamente va a ser
difícil yo creo que internacionalmente
el mundo tiene la capacidad de olvidar
porque tantas veces cruzados niños
ha cambiado posición es decir ha sido
aliado y después ha sido enemigo de
países entonces yo creo que
internacionalmente se va saber el punto
que no hemos tocado pero es china yo
creo que es china es el elefante de
europa ilustrados niños se juntan por
ahí va ok treinta segundos 20 segundos
yo creo que trump es posible que tramo
recto no olvidemos como la persona
pensemos que que pasó estos cuatro años
font sueño esperamos que sea decir una
pesadilla pues ya nos vamos
lamentablemente el tiempo se nos va
'agradezco alan riding armar más sets y
a isabel su presencia en nuestros
estudios de larga distancia ya ustedes
les damos una nueva cita la próxima
semana
[Música]